Four-year-old Gavin isn't taking any chances.
He's going straight to Santa with his list of Christmas wishes.
Yes, lots of toys.
You want lots of toys from Santa?
It's the time of year when Santa gets lots of letters.
This year, there's been some confusion...
...about whether a stamp is needed to send a letter to the North Pole.
You don't have to put a stamp on it, if you're sending a letter to Santa,...
...it'll still be sent to the North Pole.
We are prepared and ready for the letters for Santa.
He's waiting for them.
And we've been helping him do that for 30 years.
Writing letters to Santa is a tradition that predates Canada Post, dating back 200 years.
In England for instance, for a long time young children would burn the letters in a fireplace,...
...thinking that somehow, through some kind of magic,...
...the smoke from the embers would send their wishes to Santa.
Now, mailing a letter isn't the only way to reach Santa.
Turns out he's pretty high-tech.
At emailsanta.com, you can send your Christmas list in an instant with the click of a button.
As for reaching Santa these days, of course there's an app for that.
If kids live in a digital age,...
...it just makes sense to reach them where they're already playing.
And I think an app is always gonna be very easy to use.
Brooklyn's mom says it's not hard to imagine for her little one.
I'm sure she would be in a few years,...
...rather than writing a letter, she'd be typing, right?
But whether it's on paper or online, Santa says he reads all of his mail.
We have a big bag of mail every night...
...and the computer is just full of all these letters and everything.
You must be very busy.
Oh, I am.
I'm very busy all the time.
Jennifer Palisoc, Global News